instance methods, class methods and static
methods. what are they? how do they work? and
when should i use them? this video was supported
by hostinger, who's having a black friday sale.
choose your favorite web hosting plan. hostinger's
premium shared hosting plan is only 1.99 a month,
and that comes with a free domain
by the way. click the link in the
description and use coupon code MCODING
in all caps at checkout to get up to 91%
off all yearly plans. it's really easy to register
your first free domain, and if you have multiple
websites that you want to manage, it's easy to
add them and keep track of them all in one place.
if you've ever thought about making your own
website, please consider using hostinger.
instance methods, or just normal methods if you
prefer, are supposed to operate on a specific
instance of a class. when you call an instance
method on an instance of a class, that instance,
in this case "a", gets passed as the first
parameter to the method. this of course allows you
to read from or modify that specific instance of
the class. but sometimes when you write a method,
you don't really care about the specific instance
of a class, or maybe you don't have a specific
instance yet. that's a good signal that what
you're doing might be a good candidate for a class
method or a static method. here's a basic calendar
class that just stores its events in a list.
the "add_event" method should just be a normal
instance method because different calendars can
have different events. for scheduling purposes it
might be a good idea for my calendar to be able
to tell if a certain date is a weekend or not.
whether something is a weekend doesn't really
depend on any particular calendar, although it is
related to calendars. all calendars better agree
on whether or not a certain date is a weekend,
assuming of course we're ignoring people that
live close to black holes. we acknowledge that
this function doesn't care about any particular
calendar instance by deleting the self parameter
and marking it as a static method. now we can call
"is_weekend" on a date even without referring
to a specific instance of a calendar. if we
just happen to already be using an instance of
a calendar we can still use it this way, though.
next, suppose i want to be able to read a calendar
and construct one from a file. you definitely
don't need an existing instance of a calendar in
order to read one from a file. you just construct
a calendar, do some stuff, read from the file, and
then return the new calendar that you constructed.
so you might think this should be a static
method, and you could implement it that way,
but it's actually a better fit for a class method.
notice here how we're referring to the class
itself inside this method. the main problem with
this is that it breaks inheritance. here i have a
"WorkCalendar" that's inheriting from "Calendar".
if i then try to call the "from_json" method
from my work calendar, i would expect to get a
"WorkCalendar" out, but the "from_json" method
had hard-coded a plain "Calendar", so it's
going to return a plain "Calendar" instead,
probably not what you wanted. what i most likely
want is to be able to refer to whatever class
it is that happened to call this function so
that i can create an instance of that class.
well, that's exactly what "classmethod" does.
"classmethod" inserts as the first parameter
of the function the class that the method was
called from. so if i use "WorkCalendar.from_json"
then class will be "WorkCalendar" but if i just
use a plain "Calendar.from_json", then it'll be
a plain "Calendar". this is very similar to how a
normal method works, except instead of inserting
the instance it inserts the class. just like a
static method, though you can call a class method
from an instance of the class. written this way i
think it can be a little bit confusing why you're
calling something like this on an instance of the
class when that instance is just ignored though.
however, this can be useful if you want to call
a class method or a static method from a regular
one. it basically just saves you the inconvenience
of having to call "type()" on self. so that's the
basic difference functionally: an instance method
gets an implicit self parameter as its first
argument, a static method doesn't get any implicit
first argument, and the class method gets an
implicit first argument of the class. by the way,
the names "self" and "cls" are just convention,
you can call them whatever you want. that won't
affect what actually gets passed to the function.
an instance method will be passed the instance
even if you name it "cls". so don't do this,
just stick to convention and call it "self".
the only exception to that is for meta classes,
but meta classes are weird in so many ways so
don't worry about it. so what are the typical
usages of static methods and class methods? static
methods are actually pretty uncommon. static
methods generally don't use anything in the class
or any instance of the class, so why are they in
the class at all? why put "is_weekend" inside of
the calendar class instead of just making it a
freestanding function? a lot of people would argue
that it should just be a freestanding function.
get rid of "staticmethod" altogether and
just put it up here outside the class.
in most cases this is exactly what i would do. i
wouldn't use a static method, i would just have
a freestanding function. in a lot of cases this
would make even more sense than having it inside
the class because there could be other classes
that might want to use this function. something
like a time zone class or a date time class might
also want to know if something is a weekend.
why should this function be in the calendar
class as opposed to one of those other two?
but if the function really truly is somehow
tied to the class itself, then you might want
to use a static method. for instance, here's
a matrix class with a "can_multiply" method.
it takes in two matrices and tells you whether
or not their shapes are compatible in order to
multiply them. you certainly could move
it outside the class, but in that case
"can_multiply" is just too general. it loses too
much context if you move it outside the class.
if it was outside the class i would probably try
to add something like "_matrices" onto the end of
it so that i know that it's associated with that
class. the fact that i'm doing that though tells
me that it's probably intrinsic enough to the
class that it should just be part of the class.
but even still, this matrix class is
probably in a file called matrix.py
so maybe just that context is enough and
it doesn't need to be a static method.
so you can see this is why static methods
are pretty uncommonly used. they're basically
never needed, and when you do use them the
justification for doing so is shaky at best.
class methods on the other hand are extremely
common to use. and searching for them in the
standard library we see that they're almost
exclusively used for alternative constructors.
this "from_json" function actually was
an example of an alternative constructor.
they're usually called "from ..." "make ..."
or "create ..." something and their purpose is
to just make an instance using a different set
of arguments. finally, how does "staticmethod"
and "classmethod" actually work? they're actually
super simple to implement in python because of the
descriptor protocol. here's basically the entire
implementation. when you create a static method,
it wraps some function. then when you go to
retrieve the static method in order to call it,
it just ignores the instance and the class that
it was called from and it just returns the wrapped
function. technically in python 3.10 they made
static methods callable, so you can call them
even from outside a class. in this case it just
forwards the arguments to the wrapped function.
and then here's the implementation of a class
method. again, it just wraps a function and then
when you go to get the class method, it binds
the function to the owner, which is the class.
a normal function would bind to the instance,
so we just change that to the class instead.
and the reason that i'm able to do this
is because normal functions implement the
descriptor protocol. calling "__get__" on a
normal function is how you bind function to
a specific instance. so in this case we just
use that built-in ability to bind to the class
object instead of the normal instance object. and
technically the second argument is just ignored,
but i do like to just put it in there anyway.
that's all i've got, thanks to my patrons and
donors for supporting me. don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe. see you next time.